Welcome to Now You See It
The opening scene of the movie is the most important part of the movie.
It may not be the most memorable or the most complicated lens, but it is the first lens we saw.
It’s as important as our first impression of a person
Opening shots are often overlooked, especially when they are not so cool
But the director will use the opening lens to convey the theme of the movie, the premise of the story,
Or character arc. It’s like introducing a scene to us,
The opening lens introduces the whole movie to us. This introduction may be a scenery.
a character, even a computer screen, but no matter what it is, this is the most worth mentioning
Aspect. The opening shot is the information that the viewer initially received, so the director
It will make him meaningful. I want to focus on what we can do from the next
What was found in the opening shots of these movies. If you have seen this, it’s good,
If you haven't already, it's better, because you can watch these movies after watching this short film.
See how their opening shots present the entire movie. Let's start with an epic start:
2001 Space Roaming This shot begins on the back of the moon. The first one caught our eyes
It is this desolate and dead space that is far from the earth.
We can see the earth from behind the moon, and the sun rises on the side. This lens also symbolizes the dawn of mankind.
The opening lens is not a person or a group of people, it is the entire human civilization.
It shows that this movie is not just about people, but about human beings as a whole.
The sun, symbolizing life, slowly rises into our vision. Our eyes are the beginning of the cycle of life.
At the same time, the soundtrack of this lens has a thick sense of epic scale.
And this rising sun, the home we live in, the earth
Tell us that the center of this story is the creature on earth. We also know that we look out of this space from the perspective of an outsider.
The title tells us that we are on the way.
Therefore, we can learn from this opening shot that this film is about human beings, about life above the earth.
And the journey of life on earth
From this shot, we have a clear understanding of what the plot will be.
The opening shot of "2001: Space Roaming" is an amazing shot that we can remember, let's take a look
A simple opening shot can also account for a lot of information.
According to the composition of the movie in the opening shot, the position of the camera, and the action of the actor
We can find a lot of information in the movie.
In the movie "The Line of Happiness Behind the Dark Clouds", we first look at him from the back of the protagonist, and the other part we can't see.
Slow zoom pulls his head towards us, his head in the opposite direction
He said in the other direction that he wanted to apologize. He is from the position facing away from the camera
It also implies that this character is in a weak position. In this shot, we can see
The protagonist’s goal is the wrong direction, and we know that this movie will focus on him.
And what is happening to him
Take a look at this shot from "Little Miss Sunshine". What can we find?
We saw Miss Louisiana’s beauty contest in her glasses.
We soon realized that this movie is about dreams and pursuing dreams.
From her desire to become a beauty contest champion, our desire is a beauty pageant, and we have a certain impression of this dream.
It may be superficial and only focus on the surface. Because of the close-up of her eyes, Miss Louisiana is the map of her dreams.
From her lens, she can see what she wants to be.
I like the opening shot of Silent Lamb.
Because this is a very informative lens
Let's take a look at what you can find at the very beginning.
She is climbing up the rope in the middle of the picture.
This shows that we have started from her journey. She is pulling herself out of the squat
Soon we discovered that our hero is trying to break through its predicament.
I like the placement of this rope next to her.
It seems that not everyone can pull so far like her, she continues to train, pull herself
Once she got to the top, she stopped and we could hear the sound of the birds flying.
She spent a while trying to see them.
The flying bird symbolizes that our hero has achieved freedom by pulling himself up.
If you want more movies about the symbol of flying
You are very lucky, because I have done this episode before.
Our hero continues her journey, she has been training to escape the frame.
From the opening lens, we learned
Our hero is determined to save myself from the metaphorical groove that she fell into during training.
Later we saw that her training was trained at the FBI in order to save those who could not pull themselves out.
When our hero can't save those who can't save themselves, she is trapped in a ditch.
She tried to get the lamb not to call her to get help.
Every great movie has a great opening shot
The director always tells a lot of content in a short time in the opening shot.
If you want to know more about the opening lens,
You can choose to look at the angry bull, great white shark, she, but not limited to these
Because there are countless movies waiting to be opened there, being explored
Thanks for watching